james est à vous bonjour tiare bien et
brian jean christophe cambadélis le
premier secrétaire du ps était ce matin
sur i télé il a annoncé son intention de
sonder les responsables socialistes sur
la pertinence d'une candidature de
françois hollande à la présidentielle
le doute s'est installé sur sur cette
question sur le fait que françois
hollande était le candidat naturel du
camp de la gauche pour 2017
non mais je vais lui dire qu'il faut
qu'ils sont aussi les responsables
radicaux de gauche puisque il n'y a pas
qu'un parti qui soutient le gouvernement
et un à deux et cela depuis 2012 s'il
vous plaît nous avons participent nous
avons participé à la primaire citoyenne
et nous sommes dans ce gouvernement et
nous en tirerons les conséquences
d'être fier du bilan qui aura été celui
du président car nous avons toujours
soutenu les différentes mesures qui ont
été prises et si nous sommes encore au
gouvernement
c'est parce que nous sommes dans cette
équipe et que nous pensons que d'ici
les résultats escomptés notamment sur la
baisse du chômage seront là donc
françois hollande donc jean prouvost
analystes n'oublient pas ce soir des
rallyes alors il veut il veut justement
son délai les ministres qui sont pas
forcément socialistes comme manuel mâcon
donc vous s'il vous pose la question
vous allez lui répondra très
naturellement oui
françois hollande doit être notre
candidat qu'on change en parlerait déjà
avec 2 les responsables radicaux et puis
les deux ministres on va essayer de
jouer collectif et d'éviter d'avoir que
des paroles individuelle alors justement
un ministre du parti radical radical de
gauche qui est rentré récemment au
gouvernement
c'est jean michel baylet qui était le
président historique de votre parti
faire entrer dans un gouvernement un
héritier d'une dynastie politique qui
était ministre il ya 23 ans et qui a
perdu ses mandats de sénateur et de
président de conseil général est ce que
c'est dans un bon signal en terme de
renouvellement de la classe politique et
des pratiques politiques
vous savez dans une équipe de football
si vous voulez gagner l'euro il faut
qu'ils aient des défenseurs il faut
qu'ils les attaquants caennais qui
courent plus vite qu'au moins pierres
des jeunes et puis les expérimenter une
équipe gouvernementale c'est comme une
équipe de vélo coach jean-michel
le coach c'est le ministre et donc il a
une équipe avec sa diversité avec ces
jeunes c'est moins jeunes avec ses
expérimentés c'est une équipe qui doit
être homogène c'est surtout le plus
important alors au moment où il est
rentré au gouvernement il ay là il a
recasé un peu ses proches notamment
sylvia pinel dont il était proche et qui
a pris la tête du prg justement dans la
tente d'un congrès est ce que c'est une
bonne façon de procéder est ce que c'est
la bonne personne
déjà vous parliez de renouvellement
sylvia pinel je crois à moins de 40 ans
donc c'est bien déjà d'avoir une
présidente par intérim - quarante ans
une femme
donc voyez ça parler de dynastie de
vieux partie basse et au moins un parti
qui n'hésite pas à avoir une femme jeune
à sa tête et c'était que l'application
de statut de parti donc merci la crise
il un peu partisane milliards est
strictement rien de choquant au
contraire il ya un an après la défaite
de jean michel baylet au départemental
vous donc vous êtes branché jean michel
baylet non mais vous vous disiez parce
que c'est intéressant la question du
renouvellement justement se pose au prg
et vous n'excluez pas à l'époque de
badauds de briguer la présidence du
mouvement ça c'est complètement terminée
vous n'y pensez plus vous savez quand le
prison la république françois hollande
et premier ministre vous font confiance
et vous demande d'être participer à
l'équipe gouvernementale de poursuivre
votre travail vous servez votre pays et
à votre pas être grandiloquent mais pour
moi c'est une le choix et c'était une
tâche extrêmement prégnante extrêmement
importante et le choix est vite fait
entre servir son pays et servir son
parti je suis radical historiquement
plus profond de moi même avec les
valeurs de les valeurs républicaines
auxquelles je suis extrêmement attachée
et je suis très fier de servir mon pays
alors je vais vous poser une question
sans parler de jean michel baylet joue
le premier le je parle de roger gérard
schwartzenberg qui est le patron du
groupe rg à l'assemblée il a déposé il
ya quelques jours une proposition de loi
pour limiter à 30 le nombre de ministres
au sein d'une équipe gouvernementale
vous êtes 38 actuellement dans votre
équipe
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce que vous
êtes pour cette cette proposition de loi
qui vit émane de votre camp mais je
pense que quand roger gérard
schwartzenberg et minimes
c'est pas s'il a calculé le nombre de
ministres qui avaient parce que ici la
réduit s'applique et cette proposition
de loi
cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui a déposé au
gouvernement de son époque
je pense qu'il n'aurait pas déposé sa
proposition de la démagogie c'est quoi
alors ans je veux faire je sais pas il a
il avait 7 cette idée il a déposé les ca
aux arts et aux autres le soin de faire
ce qu'ils souhaitent
alors on va reparler un peu de sport sur
les réseaux sociaux notamment twitter
vous affichez régulièrement avec des
sportifs que vous que vous rencontrez on
vous voit ici avec les boxeurs de
l'insep c'était il ya quelques jours où
avec le footballeur lyonnais goûts que
vous devez connaître bafétimbi gomis il
joue plus à lyon il a joué à laisser vos
bijoux n'ont alors là vous pour ce
terrible grande-bretagne figaro c'est
que alors qu'elle quel sportif vous a le
plus impressionné lors de vos rencontres
justement par son caractère son parcours
quelqu'un qui vous a vraiment marqué
lapin il ya des tous les sportifs de une
meinau jules gardons des gens sont des
gens extrêmement respectable c'est la
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs on a
travaillé j'ai mis en place ce pacte de
performance qui permet pour beaucoup
d'entre eux d'avoir un soutien pendant
la carrière et une intégration dans une
entreprise après la carrière parce que
leur situation était très précaire et il
a fallu aussi la loi sur le statut des
sportifs votée à l'unanimité à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat pour
leur donner une sécurité une protection
sociale qu'il n'avait pas donc tous les
sportifs je veux pas en sortir un plutôt
que d'autres et je crois beaucoup aux
chances françaises à rio en olympiques
et paralympiques et un voeu pour les
prochaines semaines pour cet euro 2016
que la frontière demeure le plus loin
possible et surtout que ce soit une
grande fête populaire
je crois que nos concitoyens
besoin aussi de moments de fête et de
moments de communion collective et
patriotes avec la meilleure équipe de
france et meilleur joueur avec la
meilleure équipe de france que nous
concoctera un excellent sélectionneur
avait oublié des champs en briques de la
victoire de karim benzema en finale à
six et battre si c'est votre souhait ça
peut être mon souhait vous et ben voilà
on a fait la composition ir à sa
composition ainsi vous